[Musique]
durant vingt ans etienne mougeotte et
était aux côtés de patrick le lay le
visage de tf1 le patron des grandes
années de la chaîne où il a lancé des
émissions cultes et des animateurs qui
aujourd'hui encore sont des stars du
petit écran
etienne mougeotte très très grands pros
et véritable ami aujourd'hui l'ancien
patron de la une a décidé de tout
raconter dans le lit pouvoir aux
éditions calmann lévy dans ce livre il
raconte notamment son rapport aux
animateurs et journalistes la diriger
comme jean pierre pernaut dont il parle
comme un excellent journaliste mais
aussi l'un des plus compliqués lorsque
je lui fais une remarque ou une critique
il se justifie toujours il évoque aussi
le choix de jennifer au casting de la
première édition de star académie
à l'époque les équipes du programme
hésite entre deux candidates pour
intégrer le château était nos jeunes
nous raconte que c'est finalement pascal
[ __ ] qui tranche avec cette phrase
lapidaire
elle chante faux mais elle bouge bien il
évoque aussi la gaffe qu'il décrit comme
un animateur impossible à gérer
y a des fois y'a des trucs qui vous
arrive dans la vie enfin il se souvient
de benjamin castaldi comme un homme
drôle et malin il faut dire que depuis
son transfert les choses ont bien changé
alors voilà alors benjamin cassé merci
pour ce portrait non mais là oui c'est
vrai il se souvient de vous comme
quelqu'un de drôle et malin mais moi je
pensais je pense que c'est le meilleur
patron de tf1 de toute l'histoire de la
chaîne il était extrêmement
impressionnant moi il me faisait une
franchement il m'impressionnait me
faisait peur et quand on compte il faut
convoquer là haut je peux vous dire que
bon on révélait pas et comment je vais
lui annoncer si on a le temps pour
amusant c'est que moi je vais rester
spectateur alors je suis parti en fait
de tf1 n'est pas que j'étais chroniqueur
pour se dépêtrer pour aller sur m6 pour
faire le loft et comme j'étais quand
même sur la plus grosse chaîne française
jeudi il faut que je dise de vive voix a
été de 2 m en aller et si par hasard n'y
a pas un truc un proposer un journal
pour rester sur la chaîne est en fête
et puis il m'a fait signe mon contrat
avant que j'ai pu lui parler quand
j'étais donc dans son bureau pour y
voilà je m'en vais mal à les mettre dix
cantons qui est de tf1 on ne revient
jamais sap tortue c'est par là vous êtes
retourné
oui mais là c'était en fait la fin de
son règne manchots d'accord d'accord il
était exceptionnel rypien d'étienne
mougeotte alors sur bernard montiel
bernard montiel auront en 2003 vous avez
tenu une interview qui vous et vous avez
écouté votre place donc cette année là
vous aviez dézinguer tout le monde il en
a parlé dans son livre avait été de
mougins qui dit voilà après cette
interview ont sonné
c'est paris c'était plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour etienne mougeotte
il dit se séparer de vous était une
erreur voilà vous rendez compte ou pas
assez beau alors comment la trouvez on a
retrouvé cette interview ah bah oui je
sais la strophe
ah non mais je me suis voilà regardez
donc mon tienne il anime et vidéo gag à
l'époque
en quoi est ce qu'il avait dit non mais
regardez sur vidéo gag ce sont bien de
faire vis des blagues et en plus tu vois
les gens dans la rue quand ils me disent
assez sympa votre émission on se prend
pas la tête tu rates le début c'est pas
grave tu rates la fin c'est pas grave
moi je suis très content de le faire je
sois mon gros cul là sur les banquettes
et je touche un paquet donc je remarque
qu'il a dû se régaler s'est régalée
série et on a retrouvé l'interview en
question est ce que vous aviez déclaré
était magnifique déjà sur arthur
regardez vous aviez donnez votre avis
sur ses qualités d'animateur mais pas
que l'on regarde où le roi arthur alors
ça arthur ça c'est une très belle
réussite financière je trouve pas très
bon animateur
quand en tant qu'homme il parlait tout
même avec un prompteur il se plante
c'est qu'un dramatique mais bon faut pas
trop le dire parce qu'il ya la mamie sur
tf1
ma voix déjà j'étais en train de perdre
ma voix et perdu totalement ma voix ma
cause est perdue hot lips vous aviez
aussi lâché la rampe en parlant de tirer
ardisson écoutent et écouter se retira
j'adore l'émission d'ardisson lui est
vraiment un [ __ ] parce que je crois
qu'ils arrêtent pas de baiser les gens
ils sont tous furieux quand ils sortent
de la mettait le matin le soir ne
buvaient pas du tout à l'époque
jean-pierre foucault présentait jo zone
rouge sur tf1 oui vous une émission
produite par hervé hubert c'était le
producteur et vous aviez donnez votre
avis sur ce producteur en taclant lagaf
par la même occasion écouter alors
pourquoi cette connerie des zones rouges
là sur tf1 avec foucault j'irai pas non
plus en plus je ne paye pas alors hervé
hubert ils s'en foutent plein les
fouilles avec nous moi donc j'ai déjà eu
berck et le producteur conducteur de
l'émission aujourd'hui aussi la gaspé ça
ils s'en vantent mois et non étaient-ils
que mettre le feu et tout ça va pas que
je ne veux m'emmerder dans cette
émission sans gagner un rang je n'irai
pas à zone rouge
il a changé quand même parce que t as
fan ou mettez la pression pour faire
cette émission est un moment il y avait
des flammes et nous brûler le qi dont
vous générez la foule ne vivait pas bon
je vais vous dire pourquoi tout ça est
arrivé en fait je savais très bien que
j'allais être viré d'ailleurs etienne
mougeotte été très corrects puisque
trois mois après il m'a invité à sa
table devant tout le monde devant tout
le staff de tf1 je peux vous dire que
les cadres qui m'avait cassé grave
derrière mise en tension monte à lui
vaut rien
j'étais à côté de lui à table ou et ça
c'est un mec bien en revanche si j'ai
dit tous à l'époque c'est que c'est fait
j'ai un projet déposé un projet à
monsieur dassier à l'époque tu peux
apprendre et le signe et lui pour faire
autre chose que vidéo gag et montrer des
pendant six mois et bonnement génial et
nico book
d'abord ce serait vous faire voir et ben
ouais bah bravo bernard montiel moi
j'aime bernard montiel
bravo on le tient par le fric sinon il
serait pas là